good morning John right now I'm on a
plane to England so three weeks ago I
decided to film this video with the full
knowledge that America would be in a
frenzy over the football football
football of the Super Bowl season while
in the United Kingdom where I'm headed
they care about as much about handegg as
they do about spices other than salt so
let's be honest the portion of people
watching this video who care a lot about
football probably pretty small but that
doesn't mean that there aren't
interesting things to learn so welcome
to a nerds guide to football since one
out of every three people in America we
spending time watching football this
year the most important and interesting
question to me is why why is this sport
so successful why will we be spending a
collective 300 million man hours of time
watching the Super Bowl this year when
and this is a shocking statistic that is
the amount of time that it took to
create Wikipedia recent study found that
in the average to hour and 54 minute
long football televised broadcast a full
hour was advertisements 75 minutes was
football players milling around or
setting up for play 17 minutes was
replays of stuff that had already
happened and the actual gameplay the
amount of time that the ball was in play
in the players were playing in a three
hour long broadcast of football was 11
minutes at other 15 minutes that time
was taken up by station promos and
coaches and injured players and
celebrations and cheerleaders and stuff
so it's easy to see why people and the
rest of the world might be a little bit
puzzled by our fascination with this
sport in which apparently nothing
happens but as is so often the case the
numbers the numbers hold the answers
football is a game of anticipation small
bursts of action followed by build-up
every play a small victory for one team
or another keeping you engaged another
reason for football success is that the
games are very often closed more than 50
percent are decided by single digits and
more than 40 percent are decided by one
scoring opportunity indeed statistically
the most common spread for a football
game is three points often decided by a
single last minute field goal because of
its ability to attract and retain the
attention of a human football has become
a bit of an economic powerhouse and this
is also because all those little breaks
in play allow opportunities for
America's second favorite pastime being
advertised too when if you think I'm
getting take a look at this
statistic the average American spends
over 500 hours per year watching
television advertisements 12 full-time
work weeks per adult per year sometimes
people ask me how I have time to do so
many things and I tell them they don't
watch TV it is important to note however
that a game of football was not the top
television broadcast in America of all
time that distinction goes to the series
finale of mash retaining more than 60%
of American households however for the
very first time last year Monday Night
Football was the top rated television
series in America breaking an eight-year
long streak from American Idol all of
this success of course equals dollars
the most expensive football team in
America that would be the Dallas Cowboys
with a projected worth of more than two
point 1 billion dollars 2011 they had
226 million dollars of profit that's
more than the Raiders had in revenue
poor Raiders including food and drinks
and merchandise the average cost for an
American family afford to go to a
football game is over $500 players of
course all of this means high paychecks
the minimum you can be paid as an NFL
player is $300,000 per year the top
salary of 2011 that was 19 million
dollars going to linebacker Dwight
Freeney that man was born the same year
as me is my height and weighs exactly
100 pounds more than I do and his
financial adviser was just arrested for
embezzling two million dollars from him
brave guy but all of those high
paychecks you may have heard does not
lead to financial stability 78% of
football players are broke two years
after retirement as for how the actual
game functions there's a ball and you
have to get it into the end zone and
there's rules and plays and it's all
very physically impressive and seems
quite dangerous John I'll see you
tomorrow